Welcome back!
Now, these days,
social media has the power
to make and break careers
in the blink of a retweet.
So here to catch us up on who's
making waves online this week
is Nightly Show contributor
Franchesca Ramsey
with another installment
of Hash It Out.
-♪ ♪
-(bird tweets)
Thanks, Larry.
Last week, I got my life from
Jesse Williams' powerful speech
at the BET Awards.
(cheering and applause)
In it, he encouraged black
people to continue the fight
to end police brutality.
But not everybody enjoyed
the speech.
This past weekend,
a petition demanding
Jesse Williams be fired
from ABC's Grey's Anatomy
collected
over 25,000 signatures.
Wait, 25,000 white people
were watching the BET Awards?
(cheering and applause)
Damn!
Here's a snippet
of the petition's description.
"Jesse Williams released
a cascade
"of inappropriate,
unprofessional,
"and racist commentary
"against police officers
and Caucasians.
"I have been watching all
of Shonda's shows since day one,
"and it kills me
to take this stand,
but it is a necessary evil."
All of Shonda's shows
since day one? Really?
Even Off the Map?
You didn't even know
that was a Shonda show, did you?
-(laughter)
-No!
No one did.
I guess you missed the Grey's
episode about white privilege,
or the Ferguson-inspired episode
of Scandal,
or How to Get Away with Murder
where Viola Davis takes off
her wig, which, to be fair,
didn't really have anything
to do with racism,
but that scene was
black as hell.
(laughter,
applause and cheering)
But then, Shonda hit the haters
with this tweet.
"Um, people?
Boo don't need a petition.
#shondalandrules."
(applause and cheering)
Now is she saying
"Shondaland rules,"
or is she talking
about the rules of Shondaland?
'Cause there are a lot
of rules in Shondaland.
Like, no white after Labor Day
unless you're Olivia Pope.
You will give Viola Davis
all the awards.
And don't talk back to Shonda
unless you want to end up doing
kitty litter commercials.
I see you, Katherine Heigl.
(laughter,
applause and cheering)
But this comment
takes the loud and wrong cake.
"Jesse Williams'
comments were racist,
"and should be fired
from Grey's Anatomy.
I will no longer watch
any Rhonda Rhimes show."
(laughter)
Ma'am, who is Rhonda Rhimes?!
Is that a cross between
Ronda Rousey and LeAnn Rimes?
(laughter)
Oh, is this a show about
a kickboxing country singer?
BET just got 25,000
more white viewers.
(applause and cheering)
Look, this entire petition
and everyone who signed it
is a seven-layer bean dip
of nope.
If you think speaking out
against police brutality
is anti-cop,
does that means killing
black people is pro-cop?
Of course not!
Jesse Williams
doesn't hate cops,
and he doesn't hate
white people.
He, like all of us should,
hates the brutal murders
of black people by police
who use their fear
to inform their force.
(cheers and applause)
Let's focus our anger
on the real issue.
You want to fire Jesse Williams?
How about we fire
all those racist cops
and send their asses to jail?
(applause and cheering)
And let's...
And let us let the good cops
do their jobs.
-Yes. -Yeah.
-(applause and cheering)
And Jesse can continue
to save lives
and give me life
on Thursday nights.
-(applause and cheering)
-Franchesca Ramsey, everybody!
We'll be right back.